we're having definitely two babies and
possibly three
oh my god oh my god that's insane that's
amazing news have you guys thought of
any uh baby names yet
yeah do you guys want help with that
because we're
we could come up with some for you if
you want no
i kind of had something already yeah we
you know
don't don't be embarrassed yeah we'll
brainstorm
listen to
[Applause]
i know we have a lot to do we got a
podcast to do in a few minutes we have a
quick presentation for you guys that i
think you're gonna like you're gonna
love
let's say it's twins
jake and logan cline jake and logan
why would i want to why would i name my
kids we talked about them so much on the
show
that i thought made like an homage
yeah just kind of a tribute to china
no you could be a good father you'd be
the father that greg never was
that's not good that's an interesting
crime man okay say say it's triplets
keem phase mike why would i want to name
my kid after these three guys that i
dislike you want me to hate my kids
okay so i was thinking since you know
ela's into fashion you know we want a
strong name so
there we go how about this uh guys we
really don't need your help
calvin klein and khaleesi kline khaleesi
police savior do you realize that that's
like kkk
well klein calvin kalisi klein you're
very close i mean it starts with a c but
you're very close to kkk initially
it's not like a halloween costume idea
list
no right okay what do you think it would
do growing up with the name khaleesi
you think that kid's gonna grow up
normal i was thinking
trailer climb could be could be good you
trying to get me sued for naming my baby
trailer
okay so everyone in this office are huge
nickelback fans right no
no no yes we are okay
so hear me out if you're gonna have
twins
chad klein and kroger cline
that's a badass name
sex
dog [ __ ] and cancer dog [ __ ] and brain
cancer climb
so my suggestion is a bit more swedish
and i actually have a friend
from from my old school that was named
this so it's
called gustav daniel philip called minus
here
you want something yeah
yeah it's a great idea you know what i
really love this i'm gonna go to the
bathroom and then we'll make a decision
okay i'll be right back okay i'll put
something to ela while you're great
so hear me out i know you might be
thinking wow
we're done
i'm done with this [ __ ] all right can we
please
uh welcome everybody
the truth is
we thought we'd have enough time for the
intro we didn't
but i hope it was worth it we're uh 30
minutes late i mean
or well 45 minutes later okay come on
it was worth an hour late i mean come on
it was worth it right for the intro
with peace and love i think it was worth
it oh thank you
we praise and love with peace and love
thank you thank you
well anyway let's just cut right to this
oh well today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn
i meant mobile ela is
a birthing you're like a baby farm
how do you feel being a baby farm i feel
confused
and terrified oh hold on one sec there's
something more important
it's friday baby
friday yeah can i not hear him i can't
hear him
yeah baby yeah baby it's
friday yeah
it's friday baby right he still wasn't
connected
oh well just give me the sound bites
then
next best you got to connect your uh
audio there gabe just give me the sound
bites it's all the same
it's friday baby it's friday baby
yeah more sound bites no school friday
baby yeah let's
get back where is the weekend it's muted
friday baby
here let's just stick quietly and get
the energy
the quiet energy oh yeah
all right thank you gabe thank you take
care everybody have a good friday
the weekend baby gabe white clock gave
everywhere
that was a great one that was also worth
it
all right so anyway eli as you were
saying
right so yesterday i had an ultrasound
first one um yeah you gotta kill you
gotta
do me a favor on this okay
okay thank you i was just staring at
gabe trying to fix his audio
i figured somebody would remove it okay
sorry eli go ahead all right gabe
we have to cut the game i mean i know
it's a big announcement but it's gabe
it is friday it is friday [ __ ] fun so
your baby factory
you want to tell me about like the story
of how you found out so i went to the
ultrasound
uh without ethan because up until now
because of kovid they made us
uh they made me just go by myself but i
was loud
now they said it's a different story so
next time you can come with me
but so it was kind of shitty not to have
you there because i was like
shaking i was like oh my god yeah when
you called me you were hysterical
um so they did an ultrasound and she was
like well i see
two circles and i was like oh [ __ ]
and she was like yeah one looks good
that one also i think looks good and
then she was like and
there may be a third one and i was like
what
so i saw the ultrasound but she did say
the third one is
a lot smaller and there's a chance it's
just liquid or something
i think it's a i i i was i think it's
three
i saw the picture i know she's a doctor
and [ __ ] but i saw the picture
and you know there's definitely two
babies
and the third one looks a lot like the
other two
and i just see how you're like i see
what's going on with you ela's turned
into like
i'm like an eating machine she can't
stop eating bro
i can't i'm getting i'm right now like i
was get i was having anxiety about how
am i gonna make it through the podcast
without eating
i know the podcast we might have to just
give you i tried to like eat
just until the last minute you want some
chips but do you understand
how unusual this is even during the last
year last pregnancy oh you weren't like
no it was like oh i'm enjoying a slice
of pizza where before i didn't even
enjoy it ila goes
dan goes so we order chipotle to like we
have it on like an order queue
yeah so it goes automatically and dan's
like three
and he was like are you are you out of
your [ __ ] mind three o'clock
it's insane she's panicking because
she's gonna be
forced to sit here for whatever many
hours and not eat
um yeah i i told ethan like
yesterday i was just like snacking at
the office like i
ate two kind bars like nothing and for
me before
eating one was like impossible i would
never finish one
i find that so funny because for me i
was like two kind bears that's like a
warm-up that's like a [ __ ]
stretch for me they're heavy no they are
they're having that's like 600 calories
it's a lot of calories
[Music]
so i i personally oh thank you trisha
i think it's gonna be three i really do
oh they're saying
i should mug bang but you guys don't
understand i am
we should do it
chewing sounds like i am probably the
worst person
that i'm the most sensitive to it you
don't have to do the asmr aspect just
lots of eating
but i hate the thought of someone
hearing me eating and chewing
like if i was the listener i would want
to die you're not the listener
we got to do eating segments though
during your pregnancy we got to do food
segments on after dark
because it's like then we get to hit the
double whammy we get to eat together
and you get to feed right you don't eat
anymore you feed
yeah so some people were saying because
when we got the call
last week yeah you had some hormonal
number yeah the 392. i'll never forget
that
yeah and we didn't know what it meant
but there were some comments that were
like
um that's so high that you must you
might have
uh multiples right it's just so
interesting that i had i felt for sure
we had a feeling for sure that it's more
than one
i think it's like we both just i didn't
see three coming though
but you you so you asked me on the way
here do you think it's two or three
and it's funny we both said we think
it's three i think it's three just like
our
intuition but i don't want it to be
three because i'm scared
i'm just gonna take whatever comes my
way but i don't know how you raised
three kids at once
oh my god zac you creeped me out stop it
zach
i was like what i mean one is such a
hands-on deck
two seems like okay i can see how
two is like you know i mean people can
do hard things like people stormed
normandy i can raise two kids but a
three i don't understand how do you
carry them like first of all before we
even get to the point of raising them
how do i walk yeah either can't get over
that with three
things in my stomach do you guys know
maybe
you guys can look up if you give birth
to triplets are the babies like
lighter than usual yeah are they the
same are they gonna be smaller than if
it was one
that is a good question if you tell me
they're gonna be the same
then what i'm gonna be like all the way
to here quick google search just says
most twins and triplets grow normally in
the womb but they tend to be a little
smaller than
a a singleton baby i guess that's
because theodore was one of them
that's what it says on this dude was
eight pounds you're about to have a 24
pound baby
it was how much eight pounds yes right
exactly
four pound baby how and i'll say you're
so
like tiny okay so
and do they all have their own placenta
are they sharing space what's going on
there
um i'd have to look at them
placenta i needed more intel on it i
guess
yeah so they're sharing they're sharing
the placenta looking more
can we study today about this because i
am panicking yeah
but just now i'm reading more into it it
says triplets are generally less than
half the size of a singleton baby
yeah okay oh so they're going to be tiny
little babies
i mean i've looked in i don't know
possibly i was i seen what dancing as
well so
okay so you're saying you're not doctors
yeah yeah
dropped out never went to medical school
i'm afraid
sorry dad is it common well let me ask
you guys this you can look this up
is it common to have an uh vaginal birth
with three
children or is that like a automatic
c-section oh here's a comment i'm a twin
and me and my brother were both
eight eight and a half pounds yeah but
there you go so
so if you're a twin that makes sense
like okay that's possible with three how
do you fit three babies
even two though jesus oh yeah
again a quick google search just the top
results so i apologize that this isn't
right but most triplets and other high
order multiples are borne by c-section
yeah i think you're just going straight
to the knife on that one
which i personally think is kind of
a good thing because it's just i know
that you're afraid of that and i
totally understand but it's just like
okay we know what we're doing
dr drew has triplets oh really really
i know that no wonder he's so [ __ ] up
no
[Music]
yo but what i was saying is like you
just we go in
oh they're saying if they're sharing a
placenta it's identical twins if it's
oh they're not journals then it's not
they're not sharing
all these things yeah okay so they're
not identical because you
they're all different eggs identical is
when the eggs split but you
you have three different eggs oh they
they can already tell that
yeah because of the treatment she did
okay she released multiple eggs makes
sense
so then we would be having fraternal
twins or triplets
does it ever ha i was wondering because
when the egg splits
you get identical twins right is there
ever a case of quadruple
identical twin oh here's someone saying
um my aunt had
triplets from the same procedure they
got smaller as they came out
so the first was normal size the second
was smaller
the third was tiny that's cute it's like
the runt
that's kind of cute i don't know there's
to be a tiny little baby coming out
there
identical triplets or quadruplets are
very rare
but that sounds like it does happen
though wait what are we talking about no
no this doesn't apply to you
okay i was just wondering because
identical twins is when the eggs
separate into two i was like can you
have four identical twins because i've
never seen or heard of that but you can
apparently
crazy yes you can the odds are one in 15
million
oh that's according to the school that's
maybe higher
they should be bumping into them on the
street here's someone who had
twins i guess because she said my twins
were 5.9 and 6
pounds and also you waddle and it's not
easy
oh bro sounds reasonable but don't you
think it's kind of a relief just if you
have triplets to just
to schedule the time you go you know
exactly when
they cut you open they take them out
there's it's like here you go
it's done if it's triplets yeah i mean
yeah
you know i don't see the c-section is so
routine
nowadays too that it's uh yeah yes it is
i guess
that i guess i was a c-section baby you
are ella was too my knee yeah i know i
mean
i i have friends who had it for sure
it's not happening all the time i wasn't
i guess it's just like
zach was i was a ten pound baby at ten
pounds
i'm wait you know ethan i'm gonna lay
something on you right now yes
i was a twelve pound baby [ __ ] out of
well i guess it wasn't uh it was like 20
days late
something like that that's a lot the
doctors let that go on way too long well
yeah
i got big or mom biggest foot i had to
be in is it imaginable
no she said oh there's someone in the
chat saying i'm a triplet and i have a
brother and a sister
oh i am so curious i want to talk to
them yeah can these triplets
call calling because i need i feel like
lauren i need to learn right now
lauren can you try to call the show
because i am so curious
please i've i need to prepare for this
lauren if you're in the discord uh
uh uh dm me cause i was thinking like
okay i've got to raise
three kids at once how do i make them
all feel like special and loved and
attenti and give them all the attention
they deserve and like
because with theodore
he's been so much the focal point of
everything
i feel like we always use this music in
our old videos it's like a creepy
yeah skit definitely
yeah for sure this is like the chucky
under the bed music yeah
[Music]
um but you know what i mean it's like
how do you
bring three kids into the world at once
and make them all feel like
individuals and loved
i don't know and how do you still work
and then also giving attention to
theodore
and those two punk dogs that we have
psychotic high maintenance dogs
love me daddy shredder requires more
attention than our
son yeah feeding shredder is more
difficult than feeding theodore
uh dude anyway we'll find we're going to
find out for sure next week right
because we're going in for another
ultrasound yeah you'll get
a heartbeat i i cuz she said that you
know it's maybe three and i was like so
when am i gonna know
and she said probably next week bruh
i feel like it's gonna be a long week i
feel like i'm dying
it's on thursday i'm sure it's triplets
like i feel like i'm sure
that's my feeling too because how i'm
like behaving
bro i can't stop eating i told you last
week
it was i had such a powerful load that
day it's not about you ethan
it's not about your love just saying i
just knew it
so i have like i don't know if any of
them are
lauren i think was the name that we said
but but i have
three people that just dm me saying uh
i'm a triplet i'd love to call and talk
are you guys faking
it because how many triplets can we have
in the chat yeah i said i'm a triplet
i'd love to call in and talk our parents
thought we were twins at first just like
ethan and ela
they also use fertility treatments so i
don't know a decent amount about this
bring them okay all right yo how common
is that triplets so it's going to be
rare right
but i think it's the fertility it's the
like naturally occurring triplets gotta
be really rare
more and more people are have to do the
fertility treatments now
that's crazy what they said there's
another kind of milk
honestly when we were doing the
treatment she
she kept asking me like are you gonna be
okay if it's more than one and i always
thought like
it's gonna be two at most right she said
10 chance of twins she never said
anything about [ __ ] triplets
you know i am a quadruplet
holy [ __ ] was featured on tlc
how is there so many multi-baby people
in here
what
it's saying one in every 9 thousand
births for triplets
that is alarmingly common
fifty thousand people in the stream is
bound to be a handful one in every nine
thousand is triplets that's so common
it's the statistics vary but uh
there's no such thing as a coincidence
absolutely increases one day every 40.
we were talking about names how about no
such
thing as currency there's no such thing
as a coincidence
i love that guy so i feel like
i have to get educated so that i don't
panic because
i've learned like with the first
pregnancy i was so afraid of
uh pregnancy in general and the whole
procedure
of the delivery i was so afraid of it at
a few years of my life i almost thought
like i would never even have babies
because i was so afraid of it
but when i started looking into it more
and i read about what happens to the
body and how
like the body prepares for it and like
bones move to make space for it
it kind of calmed me down because i was
like okay well you have a magic body
i'll say that
because you're like so like you have
such a slender everyone does
everyone have babies listen i only know
about you and you're the best
because when you were like but your body
was always people in the chat
baby having a child is like death it's
like you just got to do it
you don't have a choice you know what
you know what i mean because like
everyone's got to die
how many people in this world have
literally the opposite right
i know that's a very true observation
but but it's like oh
how many people have died we're all
scared of dying right it's like oh every
living person that's ever happened or
exists on this planet has died it's like
what's the big deal we all have to do it
says the guy who's never have to give
birth
i have a caller lined up you want me to
take them in what's their name uh jess
jess yes yes let's hear from jeff one
second jess is coming in
i don't know dude hello jess are you
there
hey jess what are we in what's happening
what are we
doing what's to tell me about this you
find out you're having three babies you
can do selective reduction and
where you get rid of one of them but
they didn't do that
and all of us were about like three or
four pounds because when you're having
three you get they get like really small
because you can't i mean you can't have
like three eight or nine pound babies i
would assume
yeah that's what i feel like so
the first two babies me and my other
sister were the first two babies and we
were about like
close to four pounds but the last one
was closer to like
three like my dad said we could like fit
in the palm of his hands when we were
crazy
holy [ __ ] and are you guys like normal
size now are you all
like tiny oh yeah we're all totally like
fine
what's it like having growing up growing
up with two siblings was it weird or do
you like do you like being a triplet
i loved it my own so one
my the third one i'm not gonna like give
names because i guess that's confusing
but the third one
uh she had down syndrome um but we were
all like
best friends and my sister like the
the i say the second one because i was
the middle one but the first and second
we are like besties like my sister is my
best friend like we've done everything
together we went to college together
together no it's been amazing is there
an
older sibling or a younger sibling to
you three yeah
my mom i have my sister's like i have
another sister that's eight years older
and another one that's six years younger
so we're all kind of different and then
i have this other person that's like
done every step of my life with me at
the exact same time
like graduated high school went to
college together went to the same school
so it's like this built-in
besties sort of thing it's really it's
really cool i got really excited when i
saw you guys were having
multiples just because it's like a
built-in little bestie
that's really cool i was afraid that
maybe it's like a weird dynamic where
you feel like you
don't get enough attention or there's
like um
i i mean it might have been like that at
points when you're younger but there's
this
person that's like your best friend
who's had every single life experience
with you so no one can relate to you
more than this person
so you have it's like you have all the
attention you need from
this like best friend that you have
growing up i guess if that makes sense
uh i i love my sister and i'm i mean i
i think it's going to be the same when
you guys have kids or when you guys have
these this baby
are these babies it's really fun
it's really fun and how is your
relationship with like your
non-twin siblings uh really good
but it's different like i love my little
sister i love my older sister
but i mean it's different like it's it's
not the same it's
like i could tell uh emily my other
triplet
anything and i love her more than anyone
in the world and i love my old
my other siblings it's just a different
relationship because
like my other my older sister's a
millennial can't really relate to some
of the things that like
i've experienced and then my younger
sister's the same like she's like
14 you know so it is different i love
them
it's just different you love them just
not as much
[Laughter]
all right thank you thank you thanks for
sharing your experience with me thank
you it does make me feel no problem and
good luck you guys
i love you guys good luck it seems like
most twins have
strong bonds that's really sweet i i
don't know why i had this fear that
it's not like that but i one of our
employees is also
a twin and i asked her too and she said
exactly the same thing they're like
besties besties yeah brother brother
brother
that's kind of cute so what if we have
three twins
is theodore gonna feel alienated
um i don't know we'll have to
make sure it's gonna be the boss baby
yeah he's gonna be bored over he started
giving him speeches like
theodore you're gonna be the older
brother that comes with responsibilities
you got to take care of your younger but
i go tito we're having a baby
and he gets excited we go no we're
having two babies
i'm like well we might be having three
babies he doesn't understand
yeah he doesn't so he i guess he'll
still be two by the time
these new ones yeah he'll be he'll be
like over two and a half just over two
and a half
okay that's a i was the age gap with me
and my sister
uh was three years and i feel like
that's like
you're still close enough that you can
relate for most of your childhood you
know what i mean
yeah i think it's a good age difference
either i have some
triplets information here do you want to
hear it yeah okay
for triplet pregnancies there are pos
here's the possible combinations
trichoronic sorry each baby has a
separate placenta
dichrionic two of the babies share
placenta the third baby is separate
all three babies share one placenta wow
so wait
but could that be happening with her
treatment
having spontaneous identical quadruplets
oh well i'm not doing that
oh this is what i uh statistics vary but
some research
says confusing uh conceiving triplets
naturally occurs 1 in 900 births we
already read that
the heaviest triplet on record tipped
the scales in 2004
at a combined weight of 22 pounds
combined with and that's three that's
combined for three so they were all
under eight pounds yeah oh okay seems
reasonable that's a world record bro
22 pounds
how do you even have a three-pound baby
it's like a little it's like so small
yeah how do you do that it's like a
little pan
all right well um
well we have some other stuff to talk
about but we have
just a few minutes before the break uh
maybe maybe this uh
surprise for a boy behind me might be a
good way oh me
you know speaking of births it's uh
ian's birthday yeah go ahead and stand
up stand up stand up ian please stand up
let's go stand up
keep the round of applause going stand
up ian
please stand up
[Applause]
so um there we go stand up here one more
time stand up here
let's go here
[Applause]
all right happy birthday ian we got you
a present you want to open it
under your chair something i think
you'll like but something i absolutely
hate if that's
if that's you guys opened me under the
under the chair
yeah we hit it under the chair you know
oprah's my
biggest role model in life so i aspire
to be like her in every way
i'm switching and opening presents what
is it something
ethan hates please stand up buddy and
would love
what could that be box here hold it up
oh you know
fold them up foam
wait what is foam guys got me some foam
yeah i got a block of balm i did
oh wow
yeezys people those are sticky and
you like those right they look very
comfortable
i gotta say bro they're so ugly
but we knew you'd love it you want to
try them on i want to see what they look
like on somebody
okay i'll keep my socks on i don't want
to yeah yeah yeah
i wouldn't cause any ripple effect right
okay i'll cut back in a second i'll
throw i wouldn't recommend wearing those
without sucks period that's just a lot
just too much skin to show in public
no i think it's actually not a lot
because it's kind of closed
it's gross it's like an open-toe sandal
it's like like crocs it's like a sexy
croc yeah yeah
i would wear sock with a croc i don't
like showing my phone
but a lot of people wear it without i'm
stroking blue just say you don't like to
show
no i did a whole 180 on that i find the
thought of showing your feet like that
in public or
like disgusting i'm kind of sick
don't ruin the tag in case you want to
[Music]
it's a gift baby you could flip it i
don't care they kind of have some like
hospital right hospice vibes
and the life care
[Laughter]
it fits your outfit i'm not into it
not doing it don't listen to you they're
saying right
wait so is the size okay i heard that
they run
small uh now they feel great you want to
stand up and walk around and tell me
you want me to stand up yeah please
stand
stand up all right dan's gonna come take
food oh wow
okay we're getting a special shot okay
here we go ian is standing up with his
new yeezys he's walking over walking
around on the set over there feeling it
oh you're gonna come here wow it
literally looks like hazmat
shoes he says it's a tissue box with
holes in it
yeah he's he's making it
he's got spring in it they feel
lightweight yeah stand behind the table
behind the table ian we need to see it
honestly so here come here let's see put
your foot up looks kind of good
no it doesn't don't even pretend to
think that that looks
insanely bad it kind of looks like an
alien shoe
you know are you a fan of aliens i mean
sometimes
well ian you're out of this world you're
out of this world you gotta see the top
because it just it comes up too high
it does come up weirdly it comes up like
so high right here
they kind of feel like uh like moon moon
shoes right yeah
exactly a little bit so you're gonna
rock those we're gonna see you in those
feelings here it is the new eevee how
much was this hilo
it's actually not bad it's like 80. uh
it actually fits nice i got to say it it
somehow feels better on my foot than i
would expect yeah that's what i was
saying my easy slides are so ugly but
they're the most comfortable
slides i own yeezus what's going on with
the easiest anyway these days
i don't want to get into it it's like
it's like trump like you don't want to
talk about it i got to say it
yeah it does i do wonder if they're good
for walking
they are let me let me know
i'll report that cool all right ian are
they 3d printed
is that the reason they're
what the [ __ ] do you say i heard that
they're a 3d model
ian is supposed to know everything he
knows everything kanye
enjoy happy birthday we love you happy
birthday
stand up stand up stand up happy
birthday
what's the number what's the number
what's the age
i remember when you were a kid wait i
know how [ __ ] dude you were like
super young when you started now you're
like old
[Music]
yo when you started though ago
four years ago i needed three that was
like a young man
like a young adult his way to middle age
27 27 was i think my favorite age
but i'm saying you're on your way to
like straight up adulthood at 27.
yeah i'm on my way to the grave is what
you're saying essentially so i'm 35.
27 club baby you know what i mean
the 27 club is that's when everyone dies
right av
yes yes cool 27 club but they're all
they're all famous before they die so
right you'll join other legends although
he is oh kanye's on love's
screen it's kind of disturbing
surprised me ian are you left-handed
no oh okay and you'll be okay
that's that's part of the 27 curse all
the like jim morris and jimi hendrix
so they were all left-handed and all
died with a white white lighter in their
pocket yeah there you go with the white
that's
[ __ ] i get that song oh that's good
that legend does not google it
information google that's why the big
white lighter is about that is just
i've heard tomatoes
when you search jim morrison white
lighter you know what the first google
result
is white lighter myth yeah literally it
doesn't mean it's not real though
yes it does it literally no why are you
guys breaking the kid's heart
people don't die with white lighters yes
they do it's bad luck
it's it's real ian just don't take any
white letters with you anywhere
and thank god you're not left-handed
here in 2017
snopes published an article discrediting
the theory noting that bick did not even
begin
producing white disposable lighters
until he never said it was a pick
never said it was a big oh zach you got
to give up this one up nope
never all right let's move it on thank
you guys
crappy birthday thank you guys
appreciate it happy birthday
well it's pride month so i want to just
give a special shout out to
our lgbtq uh listeners uh
chi ev lbgtq
lbgt i just make sure you're saying that
right plus do i have to say that yeah
why not everybody anyway this one's from
wally though
[Applause]
oh my god wait does he not have teeth
happy pride month everyone how did you
do that
we are allies of cry of the gay
community of the trans community
and we got your back to the end
oh god is he saying anything
i think so he's saying no it sounds like
an old vhs tape
the loose translation is it's all love
it's all love it's all love
you can you can do that right ethan his
voice
wow that's pretty close that's really
good
though
it's actually pretty impressive thank
you pretty close anything where you
require your voice to be like
mega [ __ ] up and torn the shreds i can
do
all right let's do our ads let's do it
let's thank our ads because we're having
triplets
we need that cat thank you to expressvpn
for the baby formula
we're gonna need like a barrel of baby
purple like a literal barrel
we're gonna have to order it by the
barrel right
we're gonna start shopping at costco do
you understand what i'm saying if we
have triplets
costco is going to become our reality i
used to love going to costco
yeah but now we're going to need those
like energy level
tubs of like the berserk level of
mayonnaise tub
yeah cream cheese berserk the quantity
levels berserk
we have small medium large and berserk
is that actually a word that they use
yeah oh the size is not
you guys wanna know about expressvpn
[Music]
using the internet without express via
pan vpn
expressvpn is like going to the bathroom
and not
closing the door interesting it's that
bad
good one internet service providers like
comcast and verizon know every single
thing you do
on a website you visit isbns can also
sell this information to ad companies
and tech giants
who then use your data to target you
trust me i don't want nobody targeting
me with the [ __ ] i search
sexy anime girls i don't know i'm sorry
not that
uh what's something embarrassing the
better it's not like incriminating
butthole cream butthole thank you i
don't need butthole stream showing up on
my home page
thank you zach spoken from experience
right
absolutely have you ever bought whole
cream
uh i use uh you know sometimes when you
get like swamp ass or something like
that
oh you could like dry it out no no it's
just a lot of moisture and just like
a little excessive wiping i use a
product called um
it it's just like a it's like a vaseline
kind of thing oh for like
yeah right right here i got you bro
i got you all the way expressvpn
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet
so your online activity can't be seen by
anyone
well zach just said it on the show so
everyone knows using
expressvpn can help you in that case but
everyone else they can
it's as easy as closing the bathroom
door fire up the app
and click one button it's rated number
one by cnet wired and the verge it works
on phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can be protected
i use success expressvpn on my laptop so
i can freaking
rip all kinds of sick ass shows like
netflix japan netflix canada
just got a ton more stuff so i use it on
my laptop
and it's honestly been a game changer
you can watch
[ __ ] like in um netflix japan you get
like all the studio ghibli [ __ ]
you don't see that on american netflix
secure your online but you know also if
you're looking at anal cream and
the et cetera et cetera secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
h3 today that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 and you'll get an extra three months
free
expressvpn.com h3
we got one more by mint mobile i love
mint mobile
they're changing it up folks after years
of fine print contracts and getting
ripped off by big wireless providers
if we if we've learned anything is that
there's always a catch
and when i first heard that mint mobile
offers premium wireless devices starting
at
just fifteen dollars that's one
five i thought what's the catch but
after speaking with them and using the
service
it all makes sense it's real it's good
and it is just fifteen dollars a month
their secret sauce is that they're the
first company to sell wireless services
online only
they're cutting out the retail stores
they're cutting out the overhead
which makes sense and they're passing
the savings down to the customer
um it's that simple dan
or dan you i mean i've used me mobile
it's great there's it's it's just like
anything yeah i'm using it's unlimited
yeah it works just as well as the as the
big four
yeah unlimited fast speed i mean why do
you really need a store anyway for
i think all services i think the only
reason why people still using people
like verizon is because they'll like
give you a phone
to sign like a [ __ ] like to 20-year
contract
yeah in charge people are moving away
from that anyway
they're moving them in mobile yeah
mobile's moving them away
you know what i mean but phones are
expensive it's like what this phone
costs like two thousand dollars i mean
what the hell or was it a thousand
no not two but it's insane amount so
verizon's like come here
sweetie i'll give you a phone and
they'll lock you in for like 20 years
they're like i'll just want if you have
trip then the contracts is like if you
have triplets
you give us one of the babies i was like
i don't remember signing that
so that's why mint mobile is the [ __ ]
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15
a month it comes with unlimited talk and
text high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep the same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their 7 day
money back guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just
fifteen dollars a month to get your new
wireless plan for just fifteen dollars a
month and get your plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com h3
that's mint mobile.com h3 cut your
wireless bill to fifteen dollars a month
today at mintmoble.com
thank you thank you for the uh
thanks for the formula
[Applause]
you know
okay so here we got our first little
segment here
um this is kind of our meme hole deep
dive
the tick tock povs all right love those
so there was like a trend do you have
the holocaust one i don't see it in here
dan
okay this is the first time i heard of
these tick tock povs
is that there's like for example these
kids go
well here let me just play one they
usually have music so here we'll just
have to mute it
here's the description pov you're a
jewish little girl in the holocaust and
being inspected by the nazis
like okay thanks for the
she's perspective give me her let's keep
her i want her body i'm sorry why is
this got to be like a r word fantasy
tick tock is not going with me anymore
what's your number
oh like a tattoo
jesus that move at the end there though
i feel like she's just flattering
herself like yeah they would want me
i was like okay yeah i was so romantic
oh boy then these then there's people
that like start powdering their face
and putting like schmidt cause of death
and by the way her hair is done and
she's got makeup on
you're at a museum where you can see the
way people died
julia age 19 cause of death trump has no
need to ban
tick-tock right because of this
i was put in auschwitz camp at 19 with
my family we were forced to work it was
painful exhausting
i was told because of our religion that
we believed in i didn't fit we didn't
fit
oh no she had a sharpie come
on these people even jewish like i just
um probably not when they tell us to go
to shower yada yada
what do you make of this is this like
ins like is this like what
are we doing here understand it
it's so bizarre to me oh it's hashtag
acting
she's doing like an acting thing
this one was classic look at this [ __ ]
hi welcome to heaven
how did you die i was in a jesus christ
i am so sorry she said she died in a
auschwitz
okay why is it awkward in heaven she's
like you
she you died where
why did she make that awkward face like
why are you having internet off
is this heaven you're not supposed to
have inner awkward interactions there
just watching my algorithms get crushed
so anyway there's a bunch of these man
and so we found a whole there's just a
whole
genre of pov different povs yeah
different povs so here i'll play you
guys some
and then we we made our own povs too we
did
well we're going we're going well we're
going we're doing that in real time
so here's one pov this [ __ ] gets weird
bro
1950s pov you're in the 1950s and you
see your african-american friend being
beaten
like what
that's the caption she's just crying
you're not going to do anything
just watching i'm not getting that vibe
from this crying
she seems kind of like not that
disturbing yeah
it's like you're just not the second
part of the caption is and you have to
act like you don't care
oh oh that is
deep that is deep
bro this one's pov in the 1950s you're
at a drive-in movie theater with a
greaser
now dan said that greasers are known for
being essayists is that right
well i mean is greaser a real thing
well yeah no it was a style back in the
day yeah have you have you seen greece
yeah i think this is a movie what do i
know i know what people are liking back
then
that movie or that that musical is
pretty uh
by today's standards yeah
i haven't watched i've never been to
greece i don't get it the scene you know
dancing the john travolta
john travolta is gay how are we going to
fantasize about him being well
i mean he's rumored to be gay that's
he's not openly gay
i was never into that movie too you
never liked that i never liked it i
didn't know what to say about it
it's not i don't know dude i don't know
what to say i mean i just never could
get into it
john travolta is definitely i mean i
agree that he likely
is gay but that uh but we're just
speculating yeah you said it like
that's just like i've had an encounter
i've had well if you have first hand
were you the masseuse that was rubbing
them down we met in the mcdonald's
bathroom one night and threw it
okay
so it's just got some music pov you're
in the 1950s in a movie drive-in movie
theater with a greaser this guy's
getting ready to uh make a snack out of
you
oh what do you think no
you guys think this is a joke this is
one of the videos where i
would react to and be like i am so sorry
on behalf of
yeah yeah these are great
pov a casting director in the 1950s is
looking for his next big
lead and he thinks he found her
all very kind of like i have a cedar
right over here
my young lady
it's just music this is why we can't
play sound
play it for like a few seconds for a
couple seconds
[Music]
cut yeah cut it too long
[Laughter]
anyway do you mind if i see you uh
do you mind taking off your clothes for
me please you just see what you look
like
i'm assuming that's like the line
they'll use
oh you're gonna like this one pov you're
getting kidnapped by a vampire but it's
also a gentleman
from the 1800s it's very specific
this one i don't believe has music you
can bring up the audio pov you're
getting kidnapped by a vampire but i'm
also a british gentleman from the 1800s
trust me i'll make you scream all you
want later but right now i need to be a
good girl
this is probably the most embarrassing
thing
well as much as i'd like to eat you here
i'd like to have some class i'll take
you out to dinner first how does that
sound
okay i'm gonna come
that's all right i'll save you for
dessert
how does that sound anal sex
well let's go get some food shall we
puv you're getting kidnapped by a
vampire but i'm also a bridge gentleman
from the 1800s
that's very bad that's very hard for me
to watch
i think people love it though oh wow
because i think he's like a cute boy
that the girls love
chad is not loving it the chat is not
loving it and people love this guy too
excited he's like one of these cute boys
tick-tock cute boys i think
rock and tech wear yeah
oh no it's all got music so
um here's another one hilo pov
asking wife for breakfast in the 1950s
take note elo
be so glad you're married to a modern
respectable man yeah there's no music in
this one
ah good morning dear just catching up on
world news
but you needn't worry your little brain
about these issues what demands your
attention is some hot breakfast
and i'll tell you eggs benedict would be
divine
you're not making breakfast what seems
to be the issue
i trust the oven is broken it's not
and pray tell what is the issue just
going south for me you're
tired
i see oh my god
what's the pov why do i want it i don't
want this nobody asked for this
jesus oh my god there's so many more
pov hairy guy wakes you up what in the
god
all righty though yes these aren't time
period related these are just
other povs all right it's like a whole
this is a whole genre on tick tock
uh i just don't understand what it's for
wait good morning wait wait wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa
that's your guys's caption this guy's
actually trying to be cute right now
yeah that was without the hairy meme
right pov i just woke you up all right
queen i made you breakfast
again i am not gay and
i also made you coffee and tea and i mix
the coffee and the tea together
to make some kind of weird drink for you
it's a joke hello
wake up open your eyes okay hey
wakey wakey good morning my special
queen
this guy's [ __ ] around he did hashtag
cringe
and i also made you coffee and tea i
mixed the coffee
[Laughter]
pov you disobeyed me and wore the dress
you wanted
uh say what
oh this is the dude i know this guy
this is the guy who made the video going
what to say if she's got a
appraised kink be good for me princess
okay
you're being a good [ __ ] girl yeah
this guy's a legend
this guy's so good viewer discretion
he's advised he turned it up i'll get
lost
so you ready yeah or what the [ __ ] are
you wearing
no no i said the red one
not the blue look at me you think that's
gonna
why must you always disobey me huh huh
god damn bra don't go put on what i told
you about them bro
goddamn bra is this guy doing like uh
50 shades of grey kind of thing i guess
i guess here this is the guy who did
this one by the way
i was looking a while or not in street
podcast i just made a video about this
guy on tick tock and it's
so good hey that's not me
oh i'm ethan kleinh3 [ __ ] i forgot my
own damn name
here this is me
nope not that one next one yeah pink
try these on her you're such a good
[ __ ]
good for girl okay princess it's so good
it's so good you're such a
good [ __ ] girl be good for me okay
princess
men have no right to exist
you should be ashamed of yourself all of
you guys
he did that's enough for us all to be
embarrassed
so anyway you get the idea are any of
these worth watching or can i skip these
and get get to the
bit uh dan really like the kidnapper one
i don't know
let's do it you pov you escaped your
kidnapper
that's that's my kink oh
no no
[Laughter]
pov you escaped your kidnapper and took
his gun he caught you but you threatened
him and asked
why he's crying so he's playing the
kidnapper yeah and
we gotta play we gotta play the sound
for this one
[Music]
all right you can kill this you get the
idea
you escaped your kidnapper you took his
gun he caught you but you threatened him
and
asked why he's crying bruh
stop it
we were talking about this last night
and i got to say like a lot of people
with all these tick tock trends and
stuff like to
[ __ ] on the kids that are all into it or
whatever
but i i do think we would have been just
as cringy if this was around when we
were kids
and honestly our entire generation was
handed a massive gift by myspace just
getting nuked from orbit
in like 2012 or whenever that happened
because i was never on myspace
it was facebook before there was
facebook uh but with more
social projects it was kind of epic
though because you could customize your
[ __ ]
music on your page yeah you could put
like flame gifts and [ __ ]
lots of gifts lots of gifts top eight
but yeah a while ago
uh the company got bought out and then
they were uh
they were updating it or something and
they like [ __ ] up and
permanently wiped out like 90 of the
content that was ever on the website
so millennials were just given like a
clean slate of like
all the cringy [ __ ] we did as teenagers
which is fantastic
but um yeah these kids need to think
twice yeah this shit's gonna live on
forever i gotta tell my kids
when when our kids get old enough for
this [ __ ] just like listen
i can't tell you not to use it
just know that whatever you put out now
is gonna be there forever
and he'll say yeah [ __ ] you dad you
[ __ ] i hate you
don't tell me to live my life [ __ ] you
dad
i was like theodore in 10 years yeah
whatever some
ungrateful little punk so in a way you
kind of need to like
grow up earlier and be
wise enough to not put cringy [ __ ]
on the internet when you're young that's
hard oh you can't
you can't it's just going to happen four
kids you should have your kids watch all
the old h3 videos
help them learn about cringe not that
you're mine
no not they i'm just no i'm saying
what not to do i came off
wrong baby yeah i have a tendency to do
that
um so we made let's do our own povs i'll
go first
sure here one sec here let's see eli
wrote one for you tell me this is a good
one here read what i wrote
okay so how do we do this okay here we
go
[Music]
pov you're a jew in germany in 1941.
wait should someone else read it for you
and you just react
or oh you do it after yeah whatever it's
not yeah
okay so this is me as a jew in the 1940s
[Music]
this sucks i'm a jew in the 1940s this
sucks all jews this is just
really sucks it's a horrible time to be
alive and to be a jew
it's not a good time here hold your
empty cup if you want
you want water can you get no water no
water
save that one drop one is my last cup of
water
this is a horrible horrible time to be
jewish
that's unseen
[Applause]
thank you this could go viral it's just
horrible this is the horrible
all right eel your turn what do i do
here i wrote this for you but you can
you read the pov to her
ethan and then she can she can deliver
what she thinks is an appropriate pov
for that all right
all right hit her with it
[Music]
there you go okay pov
ela's at the doctor and just found out
she's having triplets
this is so stupid
[Music]
i don't know what to do just go man this
is really surprising
the wow [ __ ] this is so
surprising i'm having triple holy smokes
yes i'm done and this is why i'm not on
tick tock
that was good that was really good that
was the master class
all right zach zach's up what you got
zach
first i just want to point out my shirt
real quick got it
okay
we're live oh there's someone else there
all right yeah is mine ready yeah yeah
okay i'll do it
all right pov well we'll get in frame
i i can't see yeah there right here okay
you don't know i'm not there not there
not there
yes right there stop yeah
perfect pov it's the middle of the 14th
century
in the northern petty kingdom of the
holy roman empire the lord of your
manner is giving you a farm hand to wed
but he has the black death
wait
[Applause]
that's it okay wait are you the okay
all right impressive that was pretty
good i mean that's pretty comparable to
what you can't think of yeah
so wait let me get this straight you
have black death or your bride to be as
black
i have the black death and you it's you
the
pov you are my bride to be meeting
uh your arranged marriage uh uh
spouse or grace it's a rough marriage
that's open
i mean that's how it goes that's a tough
foot that's how it goes forward on
wow
it's a tough one man get in frame frame
it'd be easier if you got in frame there
a little more there it's nickelback's
final show
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
sorry you're not in the frame move the
mic with you
it's nickelback's final show there we go
chad kroger and the rest of the band
he's playing a killer [ __ ] set okay
[ __ ] yeah chad sticks out his hand
he says come with me come on stage i'll
come on this journey
come on me but don't come on me
insane
[Music]
oh okay i take his hand
no no no you're just active pov chad
what does chad react to when you walk in
yeah take my hand
this is our last dance together just
over it's over
wow powerful
very powerful that was impactful
yeah that was so strong
ian you got a pov for us uh i can i can
throw one on real quick
can i get some music which one are you
doing
the one the uh kind of the 1930s
i got you something big band
big vibes yeah okay
it's 1936
a man looking into the mirror
interesting
[Laughter]
i don't really understand why this had
to be in 1936 it's 1936
it is there's been mirrors for a long
time the first mirror
just i think they had mirrors prior and
that's going to be the scene
wow
[Applause]
we definitely got to throw that up on
tick tock
incredible ab your turn okay mine is a
two-parter has two parts but it's the
same one
am i okay i'm in frame okay pov you ask
a b
to edit 55 minutes worth of footage 10
minutes before the show
yeah no problem i got it i got it yeah i
got it okay
that's part one okay that's not what
happened
there was 30 minutes to edit 30 minutes
it wasn't 50 minutes of footage wasn't
it
it was i mean because the the multi-cam
is 55 minutes
okay okay so okay okay
part two part two okay give me some
music zach
okay
i'm trying i'm trying i don't know adobe
i don't know adobe
zack why don't you [ __ ] learn to edit
them bro
scene
[Applause]
little dramatic a little aggressive
there not exactly what happens a little
dramatic but they're all dramatic that's
that's the thing
but i just want to make clear that no no
it was on me no it was on me
no it wasn't on you i'm not i didn't
blame you i didn't mention your name
no i didn't say it was you i'm just i
never said it was your fault
i hope this doesn't make you sound like
a douche
[Laughter]
let me guess it came off wrong it came
off
[Music]
i believe love has one as well
all right pov
your love bot and ethan says
he's gonna type you like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's on me
it's showing us
oh okay one second it's not it's not
bruh it's oh you guys just gave me
gotcha oh i'm sorry i love bot do you
want to start over
let's go yeah pov
your lovebot and ethan says he's gonna
tap you lightly
with the gatsby but he hits you off with
full speed
and hits the reaction oh no
that is super tragic
oh no that's worse than surviving the
holocaust basically
[Music]
wow bad wow
wow
stand up ian stand up again stand up
and go ahead and stand up please stand
up yeah
please stand up yeah and please stand up
all right all right what year is it
all right thank you guys that was fun
i was super interesting you know i feel
like we really fulfilled the um
yeah very creative crew really fulfilled
the
job
our next topic is really interesting um
how do we even get into this fan fiction
thing
well because you were spitting all this
fantastic harry potter fan fiction
the other day oh right people were
accusing me of being like a
fan fiction yeah and somebody
somebody said to me oh uh ethan for sure
has a
wattpad account and i was like what is
that
i said what and then uh i looked into it
and uh well actually and the same people
it was on the the members discord said
uh
oh yeah there's actually a bunch of h3
fan fiction on there
so we went and looked and uh sure enough
um there's been some that's been on
there for years even
so uh we figured we'd um do a little
table read
a little uh coke zero ela's going to pee
anything
anybody want anything uh chips always
but otherwise i'm coming
grab something for yourself she's
pregnant so we're all just going taking
a casual around here
all right so you guys want some fan
fiction let's [ __ ] go
jacksepticeye h3h3 right so i believe
because there's a keemstar h3 yes indeed
oh god and then there's a um
post malone one of course uh-huh uh-huh
all right let's start with jacksepticeye
do you want to read them or do you want
to have somebody read it to you
yeah i guess if if it's about me and
maybe someone should read it
um okay i can read one to you i'll try
i'll try to
yeah yeah go ahead and read the
jacksepticeye one let's see how i feel
about it
all right so the jack the background of
the jacksepticeye by the way
is um when he came on the show long time
watcher the show will probably remember
he talked about the fact that people
make uh sexual fanfic
and uh art about him and he was not down
with it which i thought was amusing
because i always
thought it was funny but apparently they
don't like like they really don't like
the fan fiction
him and markiplier him and markiplier
but i mean like
i guess i understand but on the other
hand i don't understand at all because i
was like it's hilarious
i don't know let's see maybe i'll feel
uncomfortable
well yeah let me read this to you and
you see the thing about like
jacksepticeye markiplier too is that
there's like tons of
art of them like having graphic
encounters with each other
right yeah yeah it's like a whole
subgenre of porn practically
so okay let's see and now that we've
said that
that will definitely happen for this but
uh anyway so
here's an excerpt from uh jacksepticeye
xh3h3 by poem 13. so poem shout out to
poem 13
if you're out there ethan showed jack a
weird assortment of fanfics relating to
jack and markiplier
i'm just as gorgeous as him and way
thicker ethan thought
that's true the problem is i have never
had these types of fanfics
ethan said quite disappointed what
nobody wants to [ __ ] you jackass
while biting his lower lip ethan was i
uh he was eyeing ethan down staring at
ethan's enormous
bulge see i know this is fiction
i got i got no enormous bulge that
woodpecker was almost ready to pop out
of his pants
he was quiet and didn't even notice
ethan's 10 foot long wood in his baggy
shorts
10 foot excuse me i have to go to the
bathroom i tried to hold it in
ethan said laughing actually i'll join
you
jack replied jack entered the bed uh the
bathroom and held ethan's
thick waist jack pulled ethan closer
embracing his body i know you have a
thing for me
and then you said you weren't [ __ ] i
disagree
because i really want to [ __ ] you jack
whispered in ethan's ear no this is
serious like is this what
fanfiction because it's written like i
think it's written as a joke
i mean well i yeah i mean the fact that
it's you and jacksepticeye
i mean it even references the the
podcast so but i'm saying people thought
oh you're such
so good at fan fiction but it seems like
obviously written
as just to be amusing that people read
this and get off i don't know
i mean i feel like there's probably some
it's first of all it's part one
of two and this had uh over two thousand
views on the site
wow prior to us discovering it wow
there's a ton of comments
um yeah some of the people in the
comments i was searching for h3h3
fanfiction i did not expect someone to
actually make an ethan x jack one
someone was searching for ethan fanfic
what i'm saying i don't know how i feel
about that actually now that
yeah you're starting to feel different
now that you're hearing it right i'm not
i know i'm not a set like a sexual being
in terms of like people don't look at me
like that
uh apparently jack does jack i know
how about keemstar at h3 you want me to
read this one god
sure yeah hit me with some sexy music
zach
[Music]
ethan the now single who's single
ethan the now single and ready to mingle
jewish man started making videos on his
own i guess we got a divorce or
something in this
it's a fiction but his videos were
terrible excuse me
his fupa was gone and he didn't care
didn't need to do the chubb and tug for
ila anymore
he spent all his time on the internet
watching youtube
one day he stumbled upon a channel
called dramaalert
and he felt deeply in love the beautiful
gnome had a sexy beard and a big fupa
ethan was so in love with him that he
watched these drama alerts
all day and night even decided to track
him down
he wanted to [ __ ] him until he couldn't
walk
so frustrating
yeah i mean just for the record if me
and keem did hook up it would i would be
top for sure
important i'm not going to be bottom to
keemstar no way
[Music]
you want to post malone one
here's me and post apparently sorry
austin if you're watching this
he's not ethan whispers quietly into
austin's ear
i'm so sorry about today i can kiss it
better gross
it's so gross post shivers as ethan's
breath tickles his earlobe
pulse breaks away to stare into ethan's
[ __ ] brown eyes
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this bro yeah
they literally wrote stairs and ethan's
[ __ ] brown eyes
posts did comment on your eyes actually
because they look like hamburgers
yeah your eyes look like hamburgers
which is much more
romantic than [ __ ] brown eyes my eyes
aren't that bad i mean they're just
normal brown eyes why do you got his
glove there
yeah what color is [ __ ]
dan okay i'm just saying everybody with
around
he's got [ __ ] colored eyes i'm just
saying it's just rude
it's rude it's definitely i'm not saying
it's not rude okay i gotta make brown
your eyes look like hamburgers
their noses touch austin ethan whispered
softly
their lips met passionately and they
instantly left their humanity
and turned into sexy wild animals
clothes came off and austin could see
every
curve of ethan's pupa and
asked perfectly to find in the natural
light shining through the window
post pinned him to the bed giggling
ethan smirked and powerfully flipped
posts underneath him
i don't think i could do that yeah which
surprised post
post on the bottom and ethan on top
i like that i'm the top at least in
these fantasies
[Music]
that's really important to you i've
noticed
[Music]
yeah definitely eyes look like
hamburgers
um we have um
we were so curious about this whole
phenomenon of fan fiction
that we wanted to tap into a
psychologist someone with credentials to
explain it yeah
some literary analysis really yeah we
have a call-in
from a fan of the show he's been on many
times before
um is he has he queued up i believe he's
on the line uh uh professor are you are
you there
so many yes hello i'm here jordan
peterson is back to talk about
um fan fiction what are your thoughts on
that great
dr jordan peterson professor welcome yes
first of all thank you so much for
having me on the show congratulations uh
on all the babies thank you thank you
this um look fan fiction it
this needs to be addressed immediately
okay i
earlier i read a fan fiction about me
and and
joe rogan and it it's not real
and i really mean that i
i respect his masculinity you know he's
at the top of the competence hierarchy
without a doubt
it's like what the hell is more
important than eating elk meat all damn
day
you know right but you know i want to be
absolutely clear the fan fiction to put
it plainly
well it described me as a bottom oh and
you could be damn sure i i'm no bottom
same issue you guys really have a
problem with being bottom
well he's a masculine you make a fair
point it's
it's the bottom and this is strictly
speaking
sexual encounters is the lowest point on
the dominance hierarchy
i mean even lower and you're wearing a
[ __ ] suit basically
wow wow yeah right so
but you've been reading all this harry
potter fan fiction
yeah we were getting into shifting and
stuff
it's an interesting thing i mean it
allows for the possibility of
of divergent thinking you might say it's
you know it's like what would
professor snape's ghost you know what if
it what if he were a homosexual
you know what would it be like if if
frodo baggins
you might say is like rich off bitcoin
right that is interesting to think about
what would that look like
well you know you have to think about it
like this there's a proclivity to
uh to want to be um
well for frodo baggins like i've said
before he's extremely low on the
dominance hierarchy being a hobbit
sure and uh well he covets the ring
in some ways no
nothing like coveting sweet sweet
bitcoin
okay jordan um i was looking for more of
a site like a scientific analysis of fan
fiction but
i see you're going on about uh bilbo for
example i didn't expect that i don't
think he's a character in harry potter i
i could be mistaken i think that's lord
of the rings i was
it's a it was a jumping off point for
other fantasies
okay so what does it say what do you
think it says about people that read fan
fictions are they sick or
is that that's just a normal activity i
think they're people that are very high
in trade openness that want to explore
the possibilities you know of
of characters that they that they love
you know
shipping as you might see lots of
relationships
and things are starting to spin off of
various shows you know
ross and some other person from friends
you know going off on a love cruise or
something
i i think that um i people have very
interesting uh um proclivities
and i can't really call it much further
on that thank you thank you
appreciate you calling in to share your
perspective on that absolutely all right
take care professor
it's nice to hear from him
[Applause]
i surprised yeah he's concerned about
being a bottom too he wants to be
the chad actually are saying um
respect bottoms and stuff bottom hate
right yeah everybody loves a bottle
every
someone's got to be on the bottom yeah
it's jordan's preference to be on top
what can i do
well yours too that's what i was
pointing out when it comes to your
variants
if it comes to keemstar you know who's
on top okay
that's all i'm saying i'm not hating
bottoms
i'm hating keemstar okay
know the difference i can't control what
jordan's gonna be clarified
yeah oh
yeah so also we're being sued by triller
not much to update i think we'll have an
update by next week we gave them a
deadline
an ultimatum hey
we sent them a badass letter saying f
just take this or
[ __ ] off get the [ __ ] off i mean let's
go to the
let's sue baby let's plug it soon
let's fight this out i'm ready
i'm gonna give you a little taste of
what's to come
trailers definitely on the bottom if
they were had a human manifestation
yeah triller's the app and the company's
so shitty that jake paul literally
left them imagine being so [ __ ]
that you can't even keep your main
fighter oh no
so they were in the news
um they're in the news for inflating
their
user numbers because i was like i was
just kind of curious i'm like
how is this company not totally bankrupt
because they're competing against tick
tock
that is this behemoth app that everybody
knows and loves
and triller like if you go to the app
store
they're like not even the top 200. like
nobody is using this app
and rightfully not it's a horrible app
run by horrible people
and they just got they must be
hemorrhaging money
um don't just have the funding
i guess yeah but i think there's no way
they don't get bankrupt but listen to
this
and according to um the verge
the company claimed in october 2019 that
it had 13 million monthly active
users and 60 million app downloads
however business insider interviewed six
former employees
all of whom disputed those numbers oh
and by the way imagine what a shitty
employee you are when you're when your
former employers are coming out against
you being like nah these guys are full
of [ __ ]
that's crazy like faking your own
statistics
well that's why when they were like oh
we had like 1.5 million pay-per-view
orders everyone was like there's like
dana white was like uh they're
definitely [ __ ] lying
huh i just think i can't wait i don't
know what's gonna happen first either
they're gonna go bankrupt or this law
they might go bankrupt before this
lawsuit even
that's why they're so desperate they're
like no ethan we did we need your money
yeah yeah we're like we need them if we
don't get 50 million from you
we're going under i'm their miracle
payout
we're going under bro the fact that it
wasn't just one
employee six six six different people
who used to work for
filler all saying the same listen to
this they shared screenshots of the
trailer back end portal with journalists
showing only 2.5 million monthly active
users
it was only 2.5 wow great this was a
like near the end of 2019 beginning but
this was good time for them when trump
was talking about banning
tick tock and [ __ ] or that hadn't quite
happened yet that was in
mid uh 2020. well we
did some well here let's keep going
trailer provided a statement to business
insider which said that the former
employees were
disseminating accurate information sure
separate
inaccurate
okay meanwhile the third party mobile
analyst from
apotopia estimated that triller had only
52 million lifetime installs
a number that's vastly different than
the company would they said they had 250
million isn't that like
that's not fraud isn't that like fraud
shady as [ __ ] that sounds like some fire
festival [ __ ]
yeah a little bit joe rule are you on
the board is job rolling the board of
thriller by chance
that's not fraud it's not i would call
that uh
false advertising right he does have a
point
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this [ __ ]
i can't get over what a [ __ ] show
horribly run
the fire of organization trailers
can't get over it um
so then yesterday we're going like okay
if it's as big as they say it is
then you're gonna have to see it on the
app store because like if you go to your
phone right and go to your app store
this is really interesting i thought
there's supposed to be like this huge
social media
oh there's links so that you can do it
on your computer oh you have the app
store on the computer uh the android app
store lets you look at it directly
um and i it's it's hyperlinked to it
right there so here the
apple one doesn't but there's a third
party website that you can view it
so yeah if you these are all this is
like the rankings
and you're gonna have to scroll quite a
bit down wait where's tiktok because on
mine it was number four
well it but there isn't it because yes
it is on
android they're in the video app
category not social media
uh but this is all apps no
uh because it has youtube
creator studio that can't be true that's
not a popular app
uh right that no it's more popular than
than driller yeah here top free ads see
tick tock should be number one
because yeah again it was linked to the
category
okay this is right this is correct yeah
top free app so tick tock's number one
you have huge apps t-mobile how they
killing it so hard but okay
snapchat instagram you know what i'm
saying whatsapp
so let's go all the way down all the way
down are they even on here
no they won't be on there that's why i
linked you to the category that they're
actually in
so they're not even on here they're
below such apps as
let's see uh missed play rewards
right bye bye they're behind such
popular apps as lows as
so this is triller thriller the big
social media coming after tick tock
lows is like bruh i get more traffic
than you
the weather channel the taco bell app
taco bell app more people are [ __ ]
dude we got more people interacting with
the taco bell app than triller
this is literally empty it is a ghost
town over there
the only thing i remember hearing about
chiller too is that they kept paying off
all these super popular creators trying
to get them to come over
like i saw they bought like charlie
demilio like a rolls-royce or something
and they're paying
them a bunch of money it's like nobody
wants to go on trailer it's such a [ __ ]
app
which is ironic because part of what
they uh i believe part of their lawsuit
uh against tick tock which they're suing
them for a couple
they're suing them for patent
infringement which from what i can see
doesn't look like it's also like also
proving that they're just litigious
pieces of [ __ ] because
tick tock existed before trailer so how
the [ __ ] are they
right fringing on your patterns it's my
home yeah and um
and yeah they also were accusing tiktok
of paying creators
to not post on triller but it's like
you're paying creators to try like that
everybody does that like oh that's yeah
dude literally every
social media does that right youtube's
been doing that for a long time
so then here is okay then if you go to
okay so they're like okay maybe if we
categorize ourselves as photo and video
apps then we can get on the top charts
so if you scroll to photo video apps
they're like number
32 on here below
like you guys all kinds of stuff this is
insane let's see
where's triller here number 30. oh they
moved up
no no they're behind celeb look-alike
app
the celeb look-alike app which is has
more
downloads than triller can i please just
emphasize that
where do you see this more it's above it
it's number 29.
oh and they're
you know just a bunch of [ __ ] to your
[ __ ] apps
so anyway um yeah yes dan so um
did you send something trailer app
released
uh triller released five years ago when
did um tick tock release
well tick tock used to be musically and
it was musically was
bought by bite dance and then it changed
the name to tick-tock
but yeah the the thing about the lawsuit
is they're suing them for patent
infringement but i looked into it
and musically had a patent for a similar
thing that they're claiming that they
infringed on
that was actually issued before the
patent that triller has is so it
and because of that tick tock actually
countersued them for basically
uh it's it's not worded as slander but
effectively
you know trying to ruin their reputation
um yeah and they did this lawsuit like
you said right around the time that
trump was talking about banning tick
tock from the united states so
it seemed like an opportunistic thing to
try and
push their main competitor out of it i
feel like
they just seem to sue everybody they
just they love suing yeah they're
they bro i just i'm here just to tap
dance on their grave honestly
i'm just here to usher them peacefully
into their grave or not peacefully
i'm just here to take you by the hand
trailer and invite you
to go gently into that night and say it
wasn't your time
you're run horribly nobody likes you the
people that own the company
people who are investing are being
scammed by the way we have 100 billion
active users
i don't know that they're being scammed
disclaimer joke uh in minecraft
in minecraft and minecraft they're
scamming that they'll see maybe like he
says we're scamming a minecrafter
i have no insider information i didn't
have uh any cheats on
just like dreams but i just yeah bro i
swear i'm praying that they go
at this point i'm just i'd be happy for
them to be like no let's sue
because i just want to unleash bro
there's so much i want to say
there's so much i want to say but until
then we actually have a caller who has
some insider information about triller
um who wanted insider information yeah
really i think it's one of these
ex-employees the six employees
oh very cool yeah bring him on
okay i'm letting him in the room right
now uh hello are you there
hello
triller employee
they got him oh [ __ ] oh they got it i
got him no
they got him they served him for a
lawsuit real quick you guys got to be
careful
yo trailer trailer employee are you
there trailer employ
tough that's rough
uh oh he uh jordan
[Music]
hello i'm still on oh okay uh
i thought it was a trailer employee it's
just jordan peterson again
what's me i've never been affiliated
with truer okay
it was a miscommunication do you want to
talk about triller
well i don't know too much about it to
be honest but from
some research that i've completed so far
it's it's pretty apparent it's just a
hedonistic
abomination frankly it's designed to i
agree
entice and yeah produce sexually charged
narcissistic children
right might as well drive big white vans
around you know it's like when does it
end
good question probably one thing i
downloaded it once before if you have
you tried it
oh i've tried it i hate it i think it's
awful it's terrible
it's something in the algorithms it's
like i made a i made a short video for
for whap no likes zero it's like
wait you made a wet ass [ __ ] video well
yes i wasn't going to use
the word but
wow so you're saying you're saying you
didn't get any likes on trailer probably
because there's nobody there
well that is it's quite possible but
also you know tastefully sunburned
clinical psychologists are not really
their demographic i'll put it that way
right that's a fair point
what would you rate trailer app if you
had to give it a rating on the app store
oh
one star absolutely one star i mean it
was it was worse than my stint in
in the russian hospital and that was
that was hell wow
yeah i would give it one star too if i
rated it
i'm a tick tock man through through yeah
i feel you jordan
all right thanks for your insight buddy
i appreciate it thank you thanks for
thanks for chiming in there
yep i thought that was a trailer insider
it was just jordan peterson again
yeah miscommunication i guess
worse than his time in russian detox
he said i mean that's if that's his
opinion
yeah we'll give it a one star based on
my experience it's just horrible and
there's nobody there it's like going in
ghost town
it's like where is everybody this is a
big echo
i've never tried it where is everybody
buddy buddy buddy that's what it's like
being on trailer
you want to see something funny
are you sure yes sir watched carl
carl tuck the dick have you seen this
clip
you tell me what you think about carl
tuck the dick he goes okay tell me what
you think is happening here
pretty much everybody agreed that
segregation was the
worst thing this country was it what did
it it's like he was going to say the
best
he was about to say the best that's
funny
pretty much everybody agreed that
segregation was the
worst thing this country ever what the
hell was that is he for real
that's funny what was that did he really
you wanna slip i guess i don't know
everybody agrees it was the
worst thing that happened
so funny forcing pretty much everybody
agreed that
segregation was the worst thing
uh
[Music]
everybody agrees that the holocaust was
it was a great
terrible thing
yeah i thought that was great you know
crowder who we made a bunch of
uh we he [ __ ] on us again well he's no
but
he there's an update because crowder got
banned from youtube yeah and now he's
made
this whole big hum huh about he's coming
back so how is he coming back
well i think he was just demonetized he
was never banned right yeah he wasn't
banned he got two strikes
right which meant he was one away from a
ban yeah so he
so he just decided never a gun
well he stopped posting on youtube
because he was scared
he was scared that he was going to get a
third strike and get banned okay and
then that's when he announced that he
was suing youtube which
is which is as far as we know it just is
a total
made up there there's no lawsuit yeah
here what because a whole bunch of his
i'm back videos about how like i'm suing
and everybody's backing me up it's like
no you're not suing anyone you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're breaking the law it's like they
are they're coming for all of us
stand with one another because they're
going to pick us off one by a collection
of all the worst people you
can't be know steven can't fight this by
himself rule should not appear
glenn beck ever bro if you ever have the
quartering and a collage speaking on
your behalf just erase your line oh
that's the corner yeah
wait i was like who is this guy why does
he look familiar
his feet i just beat in my basement yeah
he loves uh
i just sent him he made it to the intro
yes that was how long
it is i couldn't find anyone better to
support him
[ __ ] the poor dreams
youtube nope he's not officially he's
literally not officially suing youtube
he's literally because so far there's no
record there's no lawsuit he sent an
intent
apparently was described to me from
emily as
he sends a like demand letter saying to
me might be dance
or i'll send a lawsuit he has not fought
sued
unless it happened in the last like 48
hours
no when i i've never been i've no one's
ever been like hey i'm going to see it
like yeah you're being sued
[ __ ] steven and crew obviously we all
care
so they're suing no they're not
they're literally not suing i love how
he's parading this around he's like dude
you're not suing anyone
there's peter in my basement he has not
sued youtube
this is the big one nope no lawsuit
again bro you're such a [ __ ]
i dare you to sue youtube you'll get
trained to drive
you kill them crowders
[Music]
anyway so here's what you can expect a
few days ago
that's why i think he'll be banned in
like basically the first week back
here is his recent he's on what's what's
it called rumbler or something
some [ __ ] that nobody pays so this
is his gay pride
month coverage and i'm like oh yeah he's
he's not going to make it one week into
this [ __ ] here
listen to this nuclear take honestly
let's look at all major historical gay
fig
you look at milk yeah you look at i mean
the one you drink or the one no
yeah these are people look i think that
if we want people to be happy you say
well that shouldn't be
so he says every major gay historical
figure is just someone with aids
which the one example that he gives
harvey milk didn't have aids he was
assassinated before aids
even existed so he's just wrong
i mean obviously that's obviously on his
first surface a wrong statement but the
one example that he gave
yeah he didn't have aids i love that
it's like
there's just what and then he goes on to
team to say oh and people with aids are
degenerates i it's like
the guy's just such a [ __ ] painful
bigot bro
honestly let's look at all major
historical gay things let's look at milk
yeah look at i mean the one you drink or
the one no you don't have milk
you look at people you usually i can't
get over how unfunny a sidekick is by
the way like
he just talks over him because he knows
the guy's just like derailing the show
you look at dallas these are people with
aids yeah these are people look i think
milk did not have aids yeah
this guy's such a [ __ ] idiot i think
that if we want people to be happy you
say well that shouldn't be an example
yeah pick a domesticated dave rubin and
make him your ambassador
wait what's wrong and then so he goes oh
well people with age shouldn't be role
models like
i'm not i've since when did having aids
become a moral
make you more morally i mean this is
from like mid 80s yeah
it's like reagan's like multiple decades
beyond this mentality
the dude is somehow like
it's so it's like hard to believe if
somebody even say that it really is i'm
just like kind of speechless who would
want to have a role model if they had
aids
what i love too is uh he's got that big
spartan thing on his desk which like
the i just like like look at this
spartan spartan armors yeah oh they
[ __ ] guys yeah the spartans are like
famously
like kids they [ __ ] kids they [ __ ]
everything
they had male lovers very big part of
their culture
interesting observation i never sucked
any ding-dongs
well and we love that about you i love
that about you alex
sucking a ding-dong
you know i think crowding wishes he was
a spartan if you know what i mean
easy
i'm just saying you're not pointing to
great examples because it's not about
because usually what we used to want to
do with children
was yeah you can have aids and be a
great person it doesn't make you morally
wrong to have aids this is so bizarre
it's just so bizarre he's trying i saw
somebody
i didn't make this point but i saw it
and i it's totally true he
he wants to be rush limbaugh he wants to
be
just that [ __ ] that you know
just appeals to the lowest common
denominator rush limbaugh famously
had a segment regularly on his show
where he would read off a list
of names of people who had died of aids
and make fun of them
wow that is [ __ ] horrific yeah now i
mean
all time pieces by the way medal of
honor recipient russia yeah from trump
super cool one of the best [ __ ] ever
lived um
he couldn't do that now though right
that's the case there's the new version
of rush limbaugh doing it right now in
front of our eyes i mean yes i don't
know does
people buy this [ __ ] i mean he does have
a lot of viewers
yep he's never sucked any ding-dongs
he's so interesting the stephen crowley
encourage them
right guide them toward the kind of
behavior that would create
the most content fulfilled and
productive member of society
now it's about making sure that they
have the greatest awareness
of the most marginalized victims that's
why they're not picking
the buzz aldrin of the gay community i'm
just saying
can you just pick a gay person buzz
aldrin is straight
isn't he buzz aldrin's straight yeah i
mean he's
trying to say give us an example he's
trying to say all of the heroes are
are of of yeah i mean he doesn't have
any examples because it's just not true
yeah everything but one example that he
gave is incorrect
so so during pride month stephen crowder
has basically taken it to himself to
spread
spread some horrible like just like
flat out wrong psychotic antiquated
homophobia super cool while having a
spartan
you know on his desk or some of the most
pro uh the people who enjoyed gay sex
more than anyone and maybe in history
sucking a ding dong oh shout out to the
spartans
could i just say in the chat i'm seeing
a lot of people say alan turing
does i pronounce it then that's the
example yeah i mean that was the first
thing that came to mind
is like the guy who broke the enigma
code and
helped the allies win world war ii
probably more than
almost any other individual and then
also
it created the the invention
of the orchestra invention the touring
machine
essentially he created the concept that
is the foundation for
all computers all computers like the
entire
world that we live in is he is probably
the most responsible if you were to
point to
and by the way and he didn't have aids
and didn't have aids and was driven
by society's homophobia to suicide was
it
yeah he was the british government uh
chemically castrated him
and uh and he ended up committing
suicide so we love
we well such a degenerate like right
stephen yeah
dude i'm so tired of homophobia it's
like just
it's just so [ __ ] pathetic
it really is pathetic it's like just
move on just move on and then you're
live steven's the kind of guy who's like
oh there's no such thing as systemic
racism
who is like openly homophobic it's like
bro you ha
you are such a victim
such a victim dude
yeah not i don't even know who he is
maybe it's buzz aldrin
although he's certainly not the first
guy to take a rocket to the moon
dude can you just say one what is that
joke what does that even mean
i don't know i think he's a drunk
what's in that mug buddy
he is he is a horrible person it's not
funny
yeah this top comment harvey milk was
not hiv positive he was assassinated
before the hiv
hiv epidemic this is just homophobia
dude it's like and this is the guy who
says debate me he doesn't literally
doesn't know [ __ ]
right so that's my little uh
take on the return of steve crowder
i give him one week max well i think
the whole point of him taking this break
is the strikes like expire
after 90 days or something so he's
waited for the two strikes has he been
gone for that long
i think so well and he's not back yet
he's announcing his return i don't think
this strikes better i think youtube has
got their eyes on them like
just waiting from the [ __ ] up because i
mean you'd think but i mean
he went through a whole giant round of
this controversy
for similar things what it was like two
years ago or something and
youtube came down on his side they they
allowed him to remain and he's been here
that was
in 2019 so but i don't know
why things have changed at what great
lengths people have to go to actually
get banned on youtube so but i think i
think he's
i think he's on his path i think he's
going to achieve what only one other
person i know of has done before
so
sucking a ding-dong
oh you guys hear about this um
people have been asking for this feature
on twitter forever do you know what it
is
to be able to edit yes twits yes
but get this it's only for premium
service that you have to pay three
dollars a month for to edit your [ __ ]
tweets
hey twitter world this is yours truly
how interesting
three bucks is not to edit my tweets i
mean i guess if you're
like a business or a influencer just
proofread your tics
okay so here so and they're unveiling
twitter blue a new subscription service
that they've used in canada in australia
the undo tweet function allows users to
preview a tweet
and set a timer that lasts up to 30
seconds before it actually posts
wow getting you one more chance to
correct or rethink
wait that's all 30 seconds 30 seconds
before it posts they get one more chance
to correct
everything then you're [ __ ]
not that useful not that useful because
sometimes you need to post it and then
people are like hey you have a title
right that's when you find out and then
you find out
dan's making noise what do you got down
there
you got the food the food is here oh you
just have a bag of chips yeah
yeah that thing is so loud
are we at that point in the show where
it's just chips out dicks out
chips out and dicks out i smuggled those
in like 30 minutes ago dan's slowly been
kicking him closer to himself
you're all eating chips ian what do you
got you got anything
ben is the loudest though why is it then
you got it i didn't even notice it
there's something wrong with you i'm not
a b and zack
i didn't even notice they're eating your
asses in here with a crinkly bag
by the way you're the same agent i'm not
eating right
i was trying to be considerate i mean
you're like i didn't even hear you but
you're the producer for crazy
for you of all people wow it is
put that up to the mic if you can hear
it here then it's too loud i can hear
you though
okay what about me i'm concerned about
the audience not you yeah i am the show
if you disrupt me it just disrupts them
this whole [ __ ] show is not real
because dan's eating chicken i was being
considered either yeah i didn't hear you
i didn't hear peep from you
or ap well i have no chips but oh okay
you did at one point right i smuggled
them exactly i mean to
dan jesus christ
the chipotle is here but by the way no
let's wrap it up
we got chipotle
the babies love chipotle three babies
dude
three i can't wait to find out
oh we're gonna do that girl i can't wait
until next thursday
i know it feels like forever your mom
better be moving in with that
i know your mom my mom
every time i tell her that she's like no
you guys will get tired of me
and i'm like i was stop it do you want
me i literally told her do you want me
to get on
two knees and beg like just stop with
those comments well is she just
i don't is she just saying that because
she doesn't want to stay there for that
long
no she's got a problem so she she that
she refused to believe that we like her
why i was really happy that she's really
great having her there
i wish that you know i wish that like
the generation of our parents would go
to therapy
they just do can you imagine the utopia
we live in if our parents got therapy
and took like antidepressants yeah yeah
magical world
magical world there'd be spaceships um
anyway if you pay for three bucks you
can this doesn't seem that useful
what else you can do you get to get
reader mode
which converts long twitter threads into
consolidated text for easy reading
this is the worst offering i've ever
heard other twitter blue features
include the ability to change the color
of twitter app icon
and the look inside the app subscribers
also have access to a dedicated customer
support team this is the worst offering
ever
i hate it well at least if they allowed
you to edit i could buy it for a gag and
like [ __ ] with people where it's like
hey guys have a great day and then after
it gets like 20 000 likes just be like
changes you can imagine yeah use your
imagination
and then everyone likes some horrible
tweet
so this is what it looks like you can
tweet and then you have a short amount
of time to cancel it it's like oh
that's not worth it i can already do
that just don't possible you gotta get
some feedback you know stupid
they should allow at least like two
minutes of public
tweet maybe well anyway to commemorate
this new
edit tweet feature we've brought out
some tweets that uh
we think the we thought we brought up
people that would benefit the most
from this new premium tweets that
they could edit for example barack obama
tweeting i'm giving back to my community
due to covet 19.
all bitcoin sent to my address below
will be sent doubled if you send 1 000 i
will send 2 000 back this is a real
tweet
uh yes a real tweet that was amazing
that was crazy
i still haven't gotten my [ __ ] money
obama so did i send him
so much money
i've been holding on to like 300
bitcoins since uh
2009. yeehaw send it all to him
i hate obama i sent him 10 i sent him
one bitcoin and i never got it back
i knew i hated obama oh boy
barack obama's the devil i sent him a
fifth of a bitcoin i never
got that back man
yeah i get no covet vaccine because
obama owes me a bitcoin
once obama pay me i'll get that vaccine
maybe
come on now come on now little dog
victory kris jenner tweeted out
i just sharted myself that's when you
fart and [ __ ] yourself on accident
real tweet
incredible tweet
you might want to edit that one roseanne
barr oh
this one was a big deal roseanne barr
muslim brotherhood and planet of the
apes had a baby equals
vj that was the tweet that caused her
downfall right
pretty much ruins her whole life pretty
amazing
oh oh i thought that [ __ ] was right oh
god
because they're like they're like um you
know she's black you can't call her an
ape that's like super racist
and then she's like i thought that [ __ ]
was what
that was so awful
[Music]
yeah that was pretty amazing
that was awesome and she had like a
whole comeback show that was like can't
yeah that was when i was like [ __ ] i
gotta like
take i gotta be careful on twitter
because people are losing their whole
lives on twitter and [ __ ]
i mean you're not doing stuff like that
oh but
yeah no yeah that's quite a bit beyond
that
like even your worst tweet i don't think
it comes close to that one
i love how it was just like a sub tweet
tweet tweet two
it was like she's just casually talking
and i oop james charles admitting to
grooming hashtag p word being a
predator i don't need to read the whole
thing around but basically it's him
saying
y'all love how many likes it has yeah
support
i love james through and through don't
think it'll turn into a scandal either
so i guess here goes nothing
yeah that didn't work out for you they
want to edit that one
chrissy teigen courtney stodden
my friday fantasy you dirt nap mmm
baby it's vile [ __ ] there's no such
thing as a coincidence
wow tying it all together with that
sound bite there
uh machine gun kelly ah this is one i
bet he wished he could undo
i wish 13 14 15 year old girls weren't
allowed to be
so hot i wouldn't feel like such a
creeper when i look at them i'm still
19. machine gun kelly wish you could go
back in time without my name
i'm just saying oh well that makes it
okay
i'm just saying keemstar i hit a dog
going 70 miles per hour on my truck
such a shitty xmas eve right now it ran
up on the highway i hate this year so
much
the funniest people we hate keemstar
i was thinking if keemstar could edit
that he could just change it to i hit a
dog
on my truck and and loved it yeah and it
was awesome i hid it on purpose i hit a
dog on purpose
so frustrating
[Laughter]
oh dream dream made the cut too the
paceman i posted the other day was
removed
by paste bin staff
yeah new classic it would take some time
to
ripen but uh right oh that was him
yeah when he went when he cheated on
hell yeah
[Laughter]
um
oh my god there's one other one i
definitely want to talk about
okay so you've heard about the bts
mcnuggee meals
yeah and people been like selling the
packaging
they are oh for sure wait like reselling
it
yeah just the mcdonald's bag just the
package because there's like you can get
a pristine one with no oil for example
that's
that's got a high value but they sell
just the packaging just the paper bag
huh no you don't want the food yeah
nuggy anytime yes
all right but watch this
an among us shaped chicken nugget
closing bed
on a mcdonald's shaped chicken nugget
from bts meal
199 997 dollars
what oh it's shaped what like a
like a among us a little area
let me go back i can't get a good
picture of it apparently but i mean it
is
definitely it's legit i mean look at
that among us snug
it's pretty solid now and luckily
mcdonald's food never expires i mean it
could
it's uh so much preservatives yeah you
don't even have to preserve it
so that cell is definitely real
we're pretty probably not i've waited
for the funding i mean when we did like
uh
the beanie the beanie thing uh the
auction
it sold for a hundred million but it
never got to the sold point
people could put any bidding oh no ebay
canceled it
right they just were like this is
turning into a nightmare right but it
got up to like 100 million
yeah but this one the bidding ended i
mean let's look at the history
yeah it looked like there were some bids
now look these are
these look like real bids
because you can see they were they were
going by a hundred increments these guys
were battling it out
no ebay doesn't i don't usually be
enough it doesn't put the money in
escrow or anything like that right
no no i don't right so somebody could
just bid i wish there was that option
because i really did want to sell the
beanie but it just turned into this
dumbass
right people mean [ __ ] show yeah
um man
interesting what do you do with this
let's say you do get that oh you frame
it you eat it
yeah i mean it would just rot away
fairly quickly it would just turn into
like a disgusting moldy
unless you preserve it somehow
formaldehyde or some [ __ ]
i guess you could do that
well congratulations to the proud owner
of the um
among us bts nuggy
well we got a mom with triplets here and
we got some chipotle
on the on the kitchen table so
i am getting to that stuff how long
we've been going dan uh
about two hours anything else you want
to say to the people at you
um we will update next week
oh baby well you do you think you'll
know for sure by next week thursday yeah
i think we will
okay fridays the baby updates yeah
friday's baby update days no
stop that triggers them bro i'm so tired
theodore will got got out of his room
three times
last night yeah it's better difficult
i'd be like theodore
this you have nine months to sort this
[ __ ] out
and by the way you have nine months to
learn how to change a diaper right
maybe he's going off babysitting duty
yeah
you better time to grow up real fast you
gotta cook for yourself figure it out
yeah
exactly here's the ipad coming in turn
for the podcast
here's the ipad don't bother me
yeah i'm gonna need your host wednesday
show
last thing this just came across the
chat so i caught it but
somebody matt fritz just donated 50
ethan please keep working on your
southern anti-vaxxer impression in my
opinion it's as good as the godfather
you know what i i agree that it's about
as good as the godfather impression but
i think we
we're coming from different sides i saw
people saying that they liked it
and you all were like is that racist i
was like yeah we are white and proud
wait what's wrong with being white
and proud yeah
come on piggy history victory
oh i took a little bit of a white proud
thing maybe a little bit of a twist
there
i wish i could have got a wide angle of
ethan and dan staring at each other in
the eye right there
come on here peggy you really want to
look at the chat let's see
i say vaccinations for cows and pigs
only
so one person is saying no it's awful
one person i like it
then i say no not racist it's not racist
hell no
this is terrible it's pain it's you
all lives matter let me tell you i love
wow it here come on here now steer i got
to give you your vaccine so you don't
catch all kind of chlamydia and die
and get off infected now oh me i never
take a vaccine
jesus is your source jesus is my source
apparently like split right in the
middle
now come on now happy pride month
did you know that all famous gay people
had aids
come on now
should probably end the show
should we switch away a couple minutes
earlier
those are not my opinions hi fred okay
thank you guys all for watching we will
be back
on monday we're shooting another
frenemies vlog next week
[Music]
i'm not gonna spoil it but it's another
fun out of studio experience that we
have planned
come on now peggy
and uh but yeah stay tuned for another
action-packed week next week
it's friday baby no school no work
come on
he was calling from a different phone
and so i i suspect that he couldn't
figure out how to unmute
what was going on it's all good i loved
that
all right guys have a great weekend take
care be safe get vaccinated and
to
uh
you're watching h two three three three
three you're watching h to the three
three three three you're watching h to
the three three
three three you're watching h h23